bueno de expectación no es una lección
muy importante recordemos que se va a
aprobar o rechazar el proyecto de nueva
constitución que viene a cerrar una vía
institucional desde que se surgió a
partir de estadio social de 2019
lo que muestran los sondeos la mayoría
de ellos Al menos que la diferencia que
hasta hace una semana era entorno A los
nueve puntos de ventaja para el rechazo
sabría estrechado la última semana a
sólo seis lo que le da cierto componente
de
expectativa no a que si se impone la
opción del rechazo o no mañana domingo y
lo segundo Rosa que genera mucho
expectaciones que está en la primera
votación con voto obligatorio en Chile
desde hace más de 10 años
tenemos padrón obligatorio o sea toda la
inscripción automática todos los
chilenos mayores de 18 años están
habilitados para votar pero es primera
vez que se hace de manera obligatoria y
no tenemos todavía cuantificados que
cuánto va a significar solo para darte
un ejemplo en la última lección
presidencial en la segunda vuelta de
diciembre del año pasado el presidente
Gabriel bolch fue elegido con 4 millones
y medio de votos sobre 8 millones y
medio de personas que fueron a votar y
es la mayor participación electoral en
nuestra historia reciente ahora se
espera que vayan entre un millón y medio
y dos millones a votar por primera vez y
cómo se espera precisamente el hecho de
que el aboto sea obligatorio como se
espera que influya en el resultado
se espera un aumento importante la
participación Obviamente que no se va a
acercar a los 15 millones Pero sí va a
pasar de 8 millones y medios las
expectativas que pasa entre a 10 o
incluso algunos hablan de 11 millones de
electores el día de mañana domingo y
precisamente uno de los puntos más
comentados acerca de esta campaña ha
sido toda la desinformación acerca de
este texto Cuáles serían los aspectos
que han causado más al ruido sobre este
esta propuesta constitucional y Quién ha
fomentado esta desinformación
Yo diría que uno aspecto más
controvertido fue el instalar a través
de toda la Constitución porque está
presente en casi todos los artículos
desde el primero Hasta los artículos
transitorios el concepto de
plurinacionalidad Es decir de que chile
dejaría de hacer una sola nación para
hacer múltiples naciones no solamente
reconocimiento de pueblo originario sino
se usa este concepto por unidad y
nacionalidad que solo está presente en
las constituciones de Bolivia y de
Ecuador y que en Chile ha generado
profunda controversia